[Music]
my name is Joey and I'm the executive
chef in wet farm and decoy restaurant
my background cooking come from Hong
Kong I'll ever go to culinary school I
grew up in the kitchen I've started cook
at 11 12 years old I was cooking street
food at the beginning then we I'm
working in the restaurant after a couple
years most American people know about
baking duck so we decide one we try to
pick it up and do a different way from
the traditional way then we try to
testing creative more sauce different
vegetable I do our own pancake retrying
butchering the dog is different with me
and my partner try to have a creativity
for the food for the praying or agreeing
as well when we do the preparation with
the dog at the beginning we washed it up
we trying to get the skin as clean as
possible otherwise it returns very dark
or burn we use the dog which is about
six and a half to seven pounds that kind
of size is really good for barbecue the
muscle and the meat different about it
we put all the five spicy flavor in
there saw in this guy in and then we use
a special nail to close the bottom which
is very important where they come from
with a head on because we are pumping
the air in their neck trying to separate
the skin between the skin and the meat
and then we put in the boiling water to
get the muscle tight we put sugar
vinegar on the top of the duck which is
helping the skin they're not crack
that's why they come out golden brown
because the sugar and vinegar
we are heading about 24 hours to make
sure the skin getting dry and more dry
that we could get the more crispy that
we get in the result we turn off the
oven to 450 degrees we cook that for 15
minute and slow down temperature around
350 and
about another 30 minutes at the last 10
minute is very important because they're
licking all the fat from the top to the
bottom we have a pan underneath it's all
duck fat I mean in general like people
have pop up like two to three wrap per
person you know for each stock here we
have a three to four sauces but the
tradition way is only like icing that's
it
we're about using sesame peanut sauce we
couldn't have a cranberry I would like
them to try different favor so they
don't feel bored you know just a
different kind of taste in each wrap
twenty thirty years ago
people know more about American Chinese
food we'll just take our restaurant the
really traditional Chinese food which is
what we ate at home is not going by from
the takeout restaurant if all these
Chinese people eating at home
there's no Chinese food why they don't
serve in the restaurant so that's why we
try to create the menu for the new
version of Chinese food
[Music]